[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite here in Park City and guys
this is the main event for me about six
or seven years ago I read Lost Girls by
Robert Coker
it's an incredible true story and and
these women here did an incredible job
bringing that to the big screen this is
my favorite film of the festival we have
director at Liz Garbus Amy Ryan
Lola Kirk Miriam shor and Anna Lawrence
thank you guys for coming in Liz let's
start with you how and when you first
get involved with this problem well
thanks for saying that
that's we appreciate that a lot I I was
sent a script called Lost Girls and I
read it and it's centered as you know
Bob's book Lost Girls tells the story of
five families who have lost a daughter
and their various struggles over the
course of about 10 different years of
trying to find them and get the
authorities to help locate these girls
to no avail what Michael worried he
wrote the script did pretty brilliantly
was he he found the story of Mary
Gilbert and made it kind of the spine of
the of the our narrative and her journey
her daughter Shannon Gilbert went
missing one night she was the last girl
as far as we know to go missing in terms
of this string of crimes and she she
raised some hell and got the police to
start looking but of course it was it
was too late and it and in doing so a
group of women came together represented
in different ways by the folks who are
here to also get justice for their loved
ones and it's that story and it's a
story of Mary Gilbert also as a mother
forgiving herself when I was a kid my
mom always used to say if everyone
missing I would go to the ends of the
earth to find you and and you know Amy
Mary Gilbert does that I feel like you
know what attracted you to this role so
many things attracted me to this role I
was sent to script called Lost Girls and
I was able to meet the director Liz
Garbus over coffee in our shared
Brooklyn neighborhood and we hit it off
really
quickly but for me quite frankly it was
playing a protagonist in a film I don't
get to do that often and not only just
wasn't just to do that but it was so
well written and she's such a powerful
character when she was ignored and she
just got louder she used her voice they
didn't hear she got louder and it was
very moving very moving
woman so can you guys talk about you
know playing the the family members of
these missing women and you know what
what they go through did you talk to any
of the actual family members to get some
insight as to you know the emotions that
they were experiencing I did not get to
talk to any of the actual characters or
the real people that are pictured in the
movie but I thought Robert co-occurs
book was so vivid and those characters
are so rich and so between the script
and that and whatever available videos
were online I was able to kind of craft
some hybrid character of who I thought
Kimberly was is yeah it's really
difficult when you're portraying someone
who's real you you so want to honor who
they are I also didn't get to meet
Lorraine who I played but I am I'm a mom
and understanding the difficulties that
she faced just living her life just just
being a person in the world it's hard
enough and then to be so summarily
dismissed and ignored as someone who's
trying to find their daughter I mean I
that journey was so painful and vivid to
me that you know I I could only hope
that I honored her memory you know in
some way by kind of going with what I
had I think that's kind of actors always
do you kind of take a leap just hope
that you get it right I obviously
couldn't meet up with Sarah because
she's in jail
but um I I think I just really had to
place myself in the character and I mean
because she's I mean she's more of like
an observer throughout this entire thing
like this is she's very young and she's
in the dark from with most of the
information about her sister she doesn't
really know where her sister is and she
doesn't really know what her sister does
either like so it's I think it was
difficult to portray her but also I
could imagine the kind of thought
process that she had to go through yeah
just having the source material to of
that book it if you could have for every
movie you ever do it's just it's so like
should we should we create a backstory
we don't have so meticulous so
well-written approach to to the media
because you know they're the the media
sort of cast these women as prostitutes
and rather instead of you know wife
daughter mother and the film really I
thought did a great job of taking that
on well I think we took it on because
Mary Gilbert took it on and the family
members took it on I mean it was I mean
you know it's one it's insult upon
injury right that your your loved one
goes missing they are so much more than
a set you know a prostitute they're
they're they're human beings with lives
and loves and brothers and sisters and
to have them reduced to this one thing
which is something that a lot of people
will think as diminishing them as a
human being is just yeah it's salt on a
very very open wound so Mary was really
furious about that and I think over the
course of time newspaper reports
actually did get better and how they
were referring to these young women but
still just recently I saw I'm an article
about the case that you know said ten
dead prostitutes you know instead of ten
dead human beings and it's just a way to
make them not important to look for yeah
Amy you know how excited were you how
important was it to you that this
project had a female director to give it
a feminine perspective well you know
it's really I you know in 32 years I
went to like what you know the list like
IMDB is like in 32 years of working I've
only worked with seven female directors
and and and the last three were three
women back-to-back late night was
fantastic you know and and and and worth
with Sarah calendula and it's listen we
had it's not only just having a female
director and a female point of view but
that there were not just one
female part in the film but like many
and some of our other cast mates
couldn't be here today but like there's
so many dynamic female complex you know
roles in this so it's it's felt like
something brand new like they're
reinventing cinema and it's wonderful
and we also have men too and they're
wonderful and we but we have ladies and
it's um you know I don't know it is it's
it's nice to be represented and it's you
know when we can do it it's no surprise
is this anyone's first Sundance yeah
what's the experience been like for you
so far in it
it's been great I don't know this is
only my second day so this is like the
first like press day Tuesday yeah but
it's great it's like a whirlwind it's so
overwhelming but so cool yeah well you
sir were you here last year for Big Time
adolescence or I had finals I would have
loved to though are we gonna see that
finally this year I don't know too much
about what that process is but I hope
because I haven't seen it either so how
did finals go then they went well okay
great yes well Lola you'd work with with
Greta Gerwig Noah Baumbach on mistress
America I'm curious are you rooting for
either of them at the Oscars that's a
tough one I loved both of their movies I
feel like I should really say that I
think they're both incredible and I
think that they both make movies with
excellent reference to incredible films
of the past so I'm just happy they're
keeping really real cinema alive unless
this is your first narrative feature as
I understand it what made you want to
take the leap from documentary
filmmaking to narrative with this
particular project and come out of the
game with this well um you know it
actually always been interested in
narrative filmmaking when I was making
films in school I did both and then I
started working as a documentarian and I
had a lot of really wonderful
opportunities and I pursued them I also
had other projects scripted projects
that I tried to mount they were always
on very tough subjects and I wasn't
successful
back then so but when I got this script
lost girls I was like this is I'm not
gonna give up or get distracted because
you know when you're mounting an
independent film you know it's you like
you just have to carry that Boulder up
the hill and if you get distracted or it
you know some another you know film
comes along they can very easily get
derailed but this one I was like no and
you know and it was a journey and I'm
glad to be here a little bit more about
that the characters jernt journey and
how you shouldn't have maybe the
greatest relationship with her daughter
and there's feelings of guilt there and
you know like Lee said that she has to
forgive herself yeah I mean married you
know extremely hard life she's a single
parent she worked a few jobs
she made really hard decisions on some
of her parenting choices which I'm sure
at the time she believed was her best
choice and what I love how the film as
she is in this search for her daughter
as Liz said before about trying to
forgive herself like in some ways you
know the drive is to make things right
and and also forgiveness for for the
guilt of where she believed she was a
horrible mother you know what Miriam and
I we were where moms and we talked about
like yeah there's that every day there's
something like oh I missed so many
opportunities to just like try to raise
these young human beings and say stellar
people but it's hard you know you do
your best and mary was doing her best I
having not met her but understanding her
circumstance that she was living in and
the obstacles she faced I got she was
doing her best we did a wonderful job
with the role you really sink your teeth
into it I could feel the anger Miriam I
I want to ask you because you you did
another Netflix movie right you just
wrapped George Clooney's new movie it's
still shooting oh okay and I play I play
a mother and wife and that one too and
instead of also I don't know that I'm
actually allowed to talk about it but
but another very emotional circumstances
actually actually gave us permission
Netflix yeah yeah so so yeah just being
you know asked to portray a person who's
far from her husband at a time when she
needs to protect our kids from the worst
the worst thing well I'm not sure
because there's a working title so I'm
not sure if we know but but it's it's
based on a book college yeah George good
morning good night see now yeah good
morning midnight is a book written by
this young woman in it is a fantastic
it's so infuriating that she's so good
at such a young age and he's took it on
and it's he's acting in it too as well
as directing which as an actor who
occasionally has directed as well I just
it's a little jaw-dropping for me
watching that process well I just want
to say one thing about there's a line
that amy has in this movie where she
he's like don't take this on yourself
right and you say I'm her mother it's
all on me I I feel like that is true as
how you feel
as a mother it's also true societally
that that it is it is it is put on the
mother all of the failures of like
anybody tends to they find the mother
and they sort of put it on there so I
feel like this movie really deals with
that in such a personal way before we
get to our fun rapid-fire supercut
questions I have to ask about Gabriel
Byrne and working with him you know how
did you settle on him so casting him and
when working with him on the shoot
Gabriel was fantastic we were so happy
when he joined the team he I mean he
infuses the character was so much
humanity and complexity and you know the
doorman role is a he's plays the police
commissioner who really bungles this
case whether it's through because of
just negligence or corruption we really
don't know and what I think Gabriel did
so brilliantly was walk the line for
different interpretations to arise from
it and yeah he just infuses it with so
much you many and Amy and Gabriel have
worked together so that was like a
really a really nice base to work from
was in treatment was that it yeah and
he's just so I mean he's so thoughtful
about the script and we spent a lot of
time together he would you know really
like you know analyze and kind of
take apart surgically every line and he
just you know he helped make the movie
better well it is a true accomplishment
you should all be very proud thank you
for coming in please if you're at
Sundance on Tuesday make sure to check
out the premiere of Lost Girls thank you
to the Kia Telluride supper suite for
hosting us thanks for coming in guys
really congratulations